hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
everyone knows i think that even though
words like
data and algorithm carry a certain
patina of objectivity with them in the
real world it's often the case
that neither the collection of data nor
the analysis of data nor the use of
algorithms
are completely objective they have
biases built into them because all of
these
facts about the world or ideas about how
data should be analyzed
are created by human beings and human
beings have their foibles right
and we see this in action in ways both
sort of profound
and trivial there are algorithms that
decide
who people should hire who should be
suspected of committing crimes
something we'll talk about in this
podcast is crash test dummies
when car crashes are done by car
companies to test them for safety
it used to be that all of the crash desk
dummies
were modeled after men none of them were
in the shape or sizes of women and as a
result
you could actually figure out xposed
facto
the designs of seat belts and things
like that for cars
were noticeably less effective for women
than for men
so as objective as we might try to be
we're going to fall a little bit short
think of it this way this is one of the
ways i like to think about it
you're standing somewhere right now
you're in a room or you're outside
you're in your car
look around and imagine trying to
describe your immediate environment to
somebody else
in a completely objective way you can
imagine doing that maybe you think you
can do that
but the fact is you can't you can say
objectively true things
right there are true things to say about
the world
you're in a car it's a toyota whatever
it is
but you're making choices along the way
there are an
infinite number of things you could say
that are objectively true
but it's you who are always going to be
a little bit fallible
and have your biases have your history
and your interests and so forth
that choose for you what features of the
environment
matter right how to divide up the
environment into the interesting facts
the uninteresting facts etc
that right there is a way that
non-objectivity
creeps into how we characterize the
world around us
so catherine dignazio today's guests is
a graduate of the mit
media lab and is currently an assistant
professor in mit's urban science and
planning department
and she's written a book with lauren
klein called data feminism and it's not
just feminism it's really
the intersection of data and algorithms
and how we
are biased and how we can fight it so
catherine is someone who is pro
data pro algorithms her message is not
that you know
science and technology are tools of the
oppressor or anything like that they can
be used to make the world a better place
but they're not always used in that way
and and not necessarily even for
pernicious reasons right you know our
biases it's
sort of a negative connotation word but
our individuality about who we are
and therefore how we see and
conceptualize the world
creeps into how we talk about it and
what we do about it whether we like it
or not
so being a little bit more conscious
being a little bit more cognitive being
a little bit more
aware of what's going on can help us
understand the world better
that's something we all want to do so
let's go
catherine dignazio welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you
thank you for having me so data feminism
the title of your book and i'm sure
we'll get into both of those and i'm
also sure that
most of the audience their eyes focus on
the word feminism right that's the
that's the thing that is going to get
people vibrating with either positive or
negative valence
but i'd like to start with the word data
a little bit because you know i'm a
physicist we have a
something that we have in mind when you
talk about data coming from experiments
finding the higgs
boson uh but in the modern world the big
data world
where we're constantly being surveilled
and tracked and things like that data
means something a little bit different
or at least the connotations are a
little bit different so
what do you in your idea what should our
audience have in mind when you just say
data something what what are the things
that are flying around in this uh sphere
of ideas
sure yeah yeah yeah no great question
the
so the data that we are referring to can
include
uh you know data from scientific
experiments of course
and obviously you know most people when
you say data their minds go to
quantitative information and so course
data includes
that um you know our definition is
pretty expansive
it's just it's information that's
collected
in a systematic way and so it's like
it's a collection of similar things at
some level
um so you know if you think about just
anything that you can put in a
spreadsheet
basically and also includes things you
can't put in a spreadsheet so i mean in
many of the
um you know the most interesting sort of
big data things
are image data for example right
and so thinking about things that are
not necessarily just
rows and columns as we encounter them in
databases
but also images uh
videos audio um different kinds of
things like that which um
which ultimately can be uh sort of
analyzed both quantitatively and
qualitatively and decomposed into
various kinds of parts
and then deployed to do different things
and
even create new things so like images
that are generated from other images and
things like that so
um and then of course in data feminism
when we're bringing a feminist lens
we also argue for thinking about
qualitative data including qualitative
data
is a very equal counterpart to
quantitative data so not kind of
creating a hierarchy out of quantitative
and qualitative data
and also really arguing for the value
for really
valuing lived experience
as a form of empirical data and that's
something that like really comes from
feminist theory and thinking and
thinking about like well for people that
have been excluded
from you know the historical canon
how do we share our stories and our data
and our
kind of evidence that we bring to the
table it's often been through
um stories and personal experiences and
lived experiences so really kind of
thinking about those as
um as empirical data obviously of a
different
nature like it's not the same thing to
say like this is my story and like
that's that's your physics experiment
those two things are different
you know um but yet at the same time
sort of not like denigrating it because
it's not um some kind of like uh
generalizable thing that everyone in the
world has also experienced
and if i'm remembering correctly you
work at the mit media lab is that right
so i graduated from the mit media lab
but i'm actually now a professor in the
department of urban studies and planning
at mit
different department are you a data
scientist there are people who call
themselves data scientists the summer
seems redundant to me but uh
it's clearly a growing field yeah i
would say i'm a data scientist
i would also say you know my
i'm really trained less as a data
scientist and more as a software
programmer so i come out of software and
database programming
um and so more from the realm of like
systems development and application
development is where i spent a long
long time um and sort of came into
data science through doing all this
database programming but also always
being interested
in art and design okay and so for me
those two things always came together
actually in maps um and so i'm a long
time
sort of cartographer and map maker and
in fact that's the course that i teach
for our
um our that's the main course i teach in
urban studies and planning is our
gis and spatial analysis course we
actually i just had a podcast a couple
weeks ago with jordan ellenberg who is a
high-powered mathematician geometer and
we talked about
uh gerrymandering and the mathematics of
figuring out whether a map is
gerrymandered or not there's
maps are surprisingly science-y i think
it's it's a very important topic
maps for exactly this reason like they
bring together science they bring
together
art and design they bring together i'm a
very visual person so they bring
together the visual side
but yeah so so that's why i love maps is
because i feel like they're like the
integration of these
two sides of the brain that they don't
often talk to each other
they don't often encounter each other
professionally but then
we find them together in maps and so
that for me is very exciting because it
can cause both like
i don't know friction but also
brilliance
but so when we say the word data as an
adjective i mean there's sort of data as
a noun which you helped define but i
guess what i'm getting at is
uh because you know it already i'm
trying to get for the non-expert
what are the steps involved in
collecting analyzing presenting data
like i think you got into the whole data
feminism thing through the
issues surrounding data visualization if
that's not
wrong so like what are what what does a
data scientist
do to go from the raw stuff of reality
to some presented data
sure yeah so you know there's
there's this exercise i do with students
um where
we start off and it's an exercise that's
about
um thinking carefully about the ways
that we
take the world and sort of capture the
world is what joanna drecker would say
is like instead of
taking data we actually are capturing
data um
it's super simple and so i go out and i
tell them to just go walk around
for like 15 minutes and your job is that
you're going to classify people's shoes
and so you have to develop some taxonomy
our classification scheme for shoes and
you have to collect at least
10 or 15 rows of data about those shoes
um and so the interesting thing is
i mean it's ostensibly a very simple
topic like most people
in the american universities have shoes
like you can find lots of them
um they come back with their data but
everybody has a different categorization
scheme
they have different ways that they've
classified shoes
and so this starts to open up some of
the complexities i think once we start
to look at
the ways in which we count things the
ways in which we
aggregate things the um the things that
we find as being
meaningful or not the same as the things
that another person would find as being
meaningful
um so this idea you know i often find
myself in the position of teaching
newcomers about data science and about
data analysis methods and
trying to help them like i'm a really um
you know the whole thread of my work is
about data literacy so trying to sort of
expose people who don't consider
themselves to be technical
to start to understand how to use some
of these methods and in fact they are
not that complicated they're just
as my colleague rahul barkov says
they're fancy ways of counting
you know um and so but so
so this is what becomes interesting
though is that um just the
human-ness of data right so even when we
think that we're being so
precise and so objective there's still
an infinite number of ways to classify
shoes
you know what i mean and that's not to
say we should never classify shoes right
and that's never useful to classify
shoes because it certainly is and
you know particularly if you're a shoe
company
um but but it's more just so that we can
start to be aware of some of the
limitations of
um what we can and can't do with data
and understand that data
in their essence are really um they are
a reduction
of the world like no row of data about a
shoe
is ever going to describe the rick rich
complexity of a shoe
right and that's okay like like we
don't need data to do that but it's just
important that we remember
that it's a reduction in complexity and
that we don't confuse the data
for the thing itself because that's sort
of where we can get into all sorts of
um troubles um is when we think like oh
these data that we just
went out and downloaded from the web
just represent these raw facts
um because in fact they're not like
they've been shaped in form
and by the institutions that have set
out resources and ways of collecting
them that have developed some
classification scheme that may have done
their own analysis and aggregation on
them and so on so
that's i love this example of the shoes
because it's exactly
what uh got me interested in your book
in the first place the
recognition that there's this tension
between a discourse
of describing the world with perfect
objectivity and
rigor so that none of our biases creep
in
with the reality that that's not a
possible thing to do right and so we
you know we might strive for it might
aspire to it but even when we do
something as innocent as
collecting data on shoes well you know
who classifies what shoe as what is an
immediate
choice the choice to look at shoes
rather than socks was a choice and so
there's
all these choices that are flavoring
what we are choosing to talk about what
of the
infinite number of facts about the world
we're choosing to collect and then
display
exactly that's exactly right that's
exactly right and it's like it's sort of
like with any
classification scheme like it could have
been done differently
and so like the important thing is to
think about well like how could it have
been done differently
and why was it done the way that it was
and understanding some of those
motivations
not necessarily because those
motivations are gonna always be
nefarious
or something like it often it's not that
like there's some evil institutional
person behind it
it's just that it was done in a certain
way for a certain purpose
which means there were things that were
left out right that there were these
paths that weren't pursued there were
these other data that were not collected
and so it's sort of drawing our
attention to
in a way like the paths not taken and
you know we talk a lot in data feminism
about missing data for example
um as a way of reflecting on what are
the structures and the powers that are
shaping
the data that we inherit and the data
that we ourselves
uh collect well and one of the points
you make is that not only does this
human choice about what to do come into
the data we collect
but then how to analyze the data what to
do about the data how to visualize the
data right these are all involving human
choices
yes exactly yeah at every stage of the
process like it's like all of these
you know the pipeline as it were at all
of these stages
of that process there's these sort of
very intentional choices there's this
kind of particular set of actors that
are working with the data
there's there's certain goals there's
certain audiences that they want to
reach
um so yeah it's sort of like um a lot of
the book is sort of deconstructing
i think some of the myths about data
science which often are things that like
data scientists themselves like they
know this really well
it's more like in the popular perception
of data science or of statistics or of
algorithms that you have to like
deconstruct that that they're these like
kind of
perfect black box systems that are going
to always perfectly predict certain
things
it's it's almost more the um the popular
narratives that we are
sort of trying to deconstruct because
any data scientists
i feel like who's worth their thought
like they know
they they know their data intimately and
they also know the limitations of their
data intimately and if they're
responsible data scientists they're not
going to be going out and like making
these wild claims
with data that are um have all these
limitations
there's actually a joke within physics
that nobody believes a theory
that comes from a theoretical physicist
except the person who proposed it
and nobody and everybody believes an
experimental result except the person
who did it because
they're very familiar with all of the
[ __ ] things that came in along the
way
that's fabulous do you think it's
generally true that people on the street
are a little bit overly trusting of the
data that they see
presented to them yeah i
yes i think so and in fact you know i
counted this in my own classes so
um prior to arriving at mit i taught at
emerson college
in the journalism department and so i
taught data analysis and data
visualization to journalists
and um they journalists are a group of
folks like they would come into the
class saying like
i'm not good at math like i don't you
know i can't do numbers
which i actually looked at their
standardized test scores was
completely alive they all did great on
standardized tests and that's fine
but you know they had this image of
themselves is like i'm a word person and
not a math person
um and one of the
having that image honestly of themselves
i think
inhibited their ability to be skeptical
of numbers because they were
overly you know they'd like download
some data on the internet and
immediately
just believe that the data were true you
know first of all
like not to kind of understand that like
they need to do in the same way
journalists are taught to do
a verification process for what kind of
quotes and facts that they put in their
articles
the same process needs to be done on a
data set that you're
inheriting from another actor or
institution that you're
that you're using so a lot of it was
like kind of teaching them about that
process
um and just having not worked with
numbers intimately like
there was a kind of over trust or like
an over
um placing of confidence
in uh the the numbers that they
inherited um
and a kind of flippage where they
imagined that if
i could see it in their writing when
they would write with numbers they were
often throwing in like
you know if there's like a decimal point
they would give all of the decimals in
like
eight places like you really don't need
to know is like 54.3.756
whatever um but you know like there's
this like um
need they felt to assert themselves with
numbers and precision
and things like that but it was
precisely because they were insecure
about it so so i mean i think these are
ways
that um that yes i think there is this
kind of placement of
faith particularly when people feel a
kind of level of insecurity or under
exposure
to data or to math or statistical ways
of thinking that like they're like oh
i'm
it triggers this like oh i'm not that
kind of person i need to place my trust
in the people that are that kind of
person
and so a lot of what i did was sort of
breaking that down and saying no in fact
like you can use you know you can
you can do this work and you know
particularly like basic descriptive
statistics or
within everybody's reach um and
you know teaching a kind of a skepticism
which is a
healthy skepticism but but a but a
deeply important one i think right now
particularly in the climate of
misinformation
and um sort of i don't know sort of bad
information
actors on the internet that is also
happening with data as well so thinking
about how do we
have a healthy skepticism and a kind of
a citizen interrogation of data sets
and being able to do a kind of a power
analysis
of a particular issue to understand how
data may have been
impacted by structural bias
and by issues of power and things like
that so and that's that's knowledge they
can draw from like that's
worlds they've been exposed to but those
are pathways that they're not just going
to come naturally i think those are
sort of muscles and skills that need to
be taught
there are streaming services that turn
our brains off
mindless entertainment and then there's
one dream the streaming service that
blows your mind
one dream has thousands of audio and
visual learning experiences
to feed your curiosity that goes so much
farther than what you'd find searching
the web
all of your favorites from the great
courses are there plus collections from
kino lorber magellan tv
craftsy and more for example i loved the
life and works of jane austen you can
find out so many facts
like one episode is completely devoted
to lady susan which wasn't even
discovered until
several decades after jane austen's
death after watching this course i'm
thinking of austin's novels in new ways
so join me and experience your own
mind-blowing moments with one dream
and right now mindscape listeners get a
special offer a
free month of unlimited access to the
entire library
go now to onedrive.com mindscape to sign
up today
that's w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
dot com slash mindscape one dream dot
com slash mindscape
well and you have examples in the book
of famous mistakes that people made you
know in the media with data for example
the one that struck me was 538
doing a story i think it was on you know
mass shootings in nigeria and they
plotted
the number of them but secretly what
they were plotting was just the number
of
stories about mass shootings in nigeria
even if they were about the same
shooting but i guess everyone makes
mistakes that's fine you know we all
misread things but
there's something about putting it in a
chart and making it look all objective
that makes us just more likely to say
well that's just a fact there's no
mistakes there
exactly exactly and so this is sort of
one of the things we talk about
in regards to data visualization which
is that our methods for data
visualization are
um almost like dangerously seductive
right
because you know we can do these really
dazzling things we use these very
precise lines
we use these geometric shapes and then
um
you know it looks by all accounts to be
quite
true and you know it's like how could we
ever question that
but in fact exactly this you know
there's this like kind of fundamental
misstep
in that project where the uh the
journalists sort of
confused the the object of analysis
basically is like instead of
actual kidnappings we were actually
talking about media reports and
kidnappings which are
really quite different things um and uh
unfortunately led to yeah like
retraction of the article and things
like that um
so yeah so let's move our way into you
know slightly less innocent
uh mistakes about or not mistakes but
ways in which we
think about and present the data you
have a wonderful quote that you sort of
uh
secretly agree with yourself yourselves
both of you uh which is that data is the
new oil
explain what that means uh to the people
who generally say it and also to you
sure yeah um so this is such an
interesting
metaphor and this metaphor was
circulating a lot
when we first started writing the book
and i feel like i hear it now
less so i don't know i should do some
google trends thing on it or something
um but i probably anyone who's following
conversations about big data has
probably heard this phrase
um it was first said we actually traced
the toasters it was first said in the
2000 like mid-2000s like around 2006
seven and then it was really boosted i
think of it as a meme so it's boosted as
this like sort of meme by the economist
magazine in i think 2011 2012
type time um when they did this whole
issue on data and all of the
kind of great profits that can result
from uh
extracting data using data from social
media to infer various things
to kind of fuel what you might call
business intelligence these days in the
corporate world
and the metaphor is really interesting
because
we can think about oil and we can think
about data
and in fact the verbs that we use
about both of those things really line
up so we extract
we mine we clean we refine
we process like all of these are
metaphors of for oil they're not
metaphors they're things we do with oil
and there are metaphors that we use for
working with data
um which is very interesting because oil
is quite
extractive right like oil is an industry
of extraction and so
the interesting thing with um the
metaphor when
folks like the economist are using it is
like they're using it in a very
positive way meaning profit
like we can extract this natural
resource uh sort of quote unquote
natural resource in the case of data
um and then you know kind of clean
process analyze
deploy whatever um and it will yield
great
riches and profits um but then you know
the question is always
sort of like for whom we raise that a
lot in the book is that we call them who
questions and that's often what feminism
is good for it's good for asking who
questions so it's like
even in the case of oil you look at like
well who
who benefits from oil like if we're
saying data is the new oil and that's a
good thing who has benefited from oil
from in the past
and what kind of uh sort of
externalities have been
uh sort of created in the process and
who has borne the brunt of those
um and so so yeah we sort of unpacked
that metaphor
um and don't disagree
in the sense that like i think it's an
apt metaphor to describe what a lot of
corporations are doing with data if you
look around the companies that are
making
the most money with data right now are
the companies that are
um you know they have the resources to
collect store
analyze deploy etc um these data driven
products and services
um but it's again like i think that
metaphor of extraction is something we
really need to think about in the
process well i guess
i mean to me it's it's quite obvious
that
oil as a concept has is a double-edged
sword right has many good things about
it
has helped industrialize the world
increase standards of living
it's pretty clear there's also bad
things about it climate change
and i would argue that it also has led
to massive
inequality some people get rich others
don't and the data is the new oil
uh metaphor lines those up and it sounds
exactly right i mean it
is it exactly right i mean do you think
that the data has this property
that it will uh have just as many bad
not me i just shouldn't even say just as
many i don't know what the metric or the
measure is but
very noticeable bad properties bad
effects just like you will have good
effects
yeah yeah i think so i mean i think in
the sense of
um thinking about like what are the
negative externalities
created by this the data economy
which some people i don't know if you've
heard this the other metaphor people
have been using is the fourth industrial
revolution
around that okay the sort of big data
economy i don't know i scoff a little
bit at that i have to say
because again it's like you know for who
like who is benefiting um and you know
one of the interesting things with
data and the negative externalities that
these um
that are created by the kind of big data
economy
is that the externalities
are very similar in a sense like the
negative externalities are very similar
to the ones that oil creates so like
if you think about like even just one of
facebook's data centers
that was located in new mexico cost
something like 30 million dollars a
month in electricity to operate
like this is a tremendous uh sort of
ecological energy intensive
sort of earth exploiting uh thing
to be basically just feeling us to
talk to each other yeah and so like
so so thinking about like there there
are environmental
sort of costs to the the cloud as it
were
um but then there's also all of these um
social and uh sort of in
inequality generating costs as well and
we go into some of those in the book
uh too wherein you know if the power of
data is really centralized in the hands
of
large actors because that's really who
have the resources to be able to
mobilize it
they're going to use it to their benefit
and they're not necessarily going to use
it to the benefit of
sort of human health and wellness more
generally speaking
right and so i think that's a big
problem if like
if it's really the corporations and to
some extent the like elite governments
and universities that can mobilize data
and the rest of us are just kind of
uh left in the dust and and that's a
concern centered
on i guess data plutocrats if that if
that's
a category of people we can point to but
you also make the point in the book that
even
among data scientists people who we
would
imagine are trying to be objective and
finding true things about the world
there are value systems that have sort
of sneaky choices built into them so
there are values that are valorized i
guess i'm running out of vocabulary
words here but
things like ethics and fairness and
accountability
and all of these sound great but they
can be used
to actually silence voices that are
being slightly contrary and so forth
whereas other values like
uh fairness or equality sorry fairness
was the other category justice or uh
equity
are not talked about as much so they
maybe say something about how it's not
just the plutocrats it's even the
scientists who sort of
maybe even innocently stumble their way
into
putting these values in a hierarchy
totally
yeah thanks for bringing that up the um
you know
yeah one of the observations that we
make you know so first of all it's
i think one it's very encouraging that
there are there's a lot of computer
scientists right now um and a lot of
folks in the technical community
are talking about uh what it commonly
goes by is fairness trans uh
accountability and transparency
um are the things you know there's like
kind of a whole set of conferences that
are organized on these topics
what that work tends to cover is
work that's looking at algorithmic
discrimination
discrimination and bias in large data
sets and training data sets
um you know running from you know text
natural language processing to images
and things like this and then thinking
about
like how do we make these things more
fair um
but then there's been some interesting
pushback on their work and we're not the
only ones
doing that same well like why are these
particular values this like fairness
accountability transparency like why are
these the set of things that we're
organizing around um and in particular
because
um a lot of work and this is not all the
work in the space i don't want to like
be
caricaturing it or something um but
a good amount of the work in this space
when you take a concept like
fairness often what these things try to
do
is say okay well let's say we have some
discriminatory system
like credit lending or something like
that
and what we're going to do with our
speculative algorithm
is we're going to just you know tune
these knobs and levers
so that um race any kind of racial bias
or any kind of gender bias is sort of
like
um excluded from the system you kind of
like get the bias out of the system
and so it's not to say that those
approaches have no
value um but at the same point
one of the things we would say in in
response is that they're actually not
addressing they don't come with a full
kind of uh
conception of the problem right like so
they're not coming with a kind of like
root cause analysis of like how did we
get to this point
um and how do we get to the point that
um
uh lending to black folks in the united
states is perceived as higher risk
this is through centuries of like really
deliberate
um sort of design and discrimination
that's been built in
from kind of like the very beginning
post um
civil wars we've had all sorts of um in
a way big data tools
like redlining racial covenants um
you know uh both informal and formal uh
legal tools
um that have worked to keep that kind of
system in place
and so you know just looking at it
let's say like mathematically within a
kind of a closed system
unfortunately fails to account for these
hundreds of years of history right
and it almost invariably the work that
starts with this fairness lens is like
starting from like
time equals t equals zero or something
you know and rather than saying actually
we need to take
like the past 200 years into account
like that needs to be part of the model
that's been part of the data
so like that would be the approach
that's about equity
and justice and so like that's that's in
a way like the
the challenge is like how how do we do
that and we can't do that in a race
and gender-blind way like it just
doesn't work like that because history
is not raised blind and gender-blind
right we have to acknowledge
that past and we have to account for it
somehow in our systems
so like um yeah i mean maybe we can get
some
some good examples on the table here to
ground people's thoughts because i think
that there is
an extremely naive point of view which
would just say look if you have an
algorithm or if you have a data set by
definition it can't be biased it's just
a computer i mean i say that's a very
naive point of view but i know people
who have it
of course in the real world algorithms
are trained on on data sets and who
chooses which data set and what history
is the data set reflecting i know
one that struck me very vividly recently
was a fun thing going around twitter i
think it came out after your book but
you know take a sentence like she won
the nobel prize
and put it in google translate into a
language that does not have gendered
pronouns and then translate it back to
english and it's always he won the nobel
prize when it comes back
right and so i mean maybe explain more
about how
and examples of how uh these biases
from history or from ignoring history
creep into purportedly objective
algorithms
exactly yeah and something see this is
great because i think this goes back to
the other topic we're talking about was
that
it's that kind of um faith like an over
overplaced faith in the systems that
they are objective and that they are
going to work like that
um so yeah so these things happen
because again it goes back to the human
constructed
nature of the data sets right like if
we're going to make
um let's take facial recognition which
we talk about in the book right
so if we're going to make a system that
recognizes a face
and is able to distinguish a face um
as opposed to the background in a
photograph um
we need training data because like the
system needs to be able to look at a
bunch of
images and um have ones that have
already been annotated and say oh this
one's a face
and here's the exact location of the
face and you know looking at
many many many of those um it's going to
teach the system
uh where the face is and what faces look
like and so on
um but one of the things that for
example you know i look at the work of
joy boiling weenie who's a colleague at
mit
she's a ghanaian american she has very
dark skin
um and she sat down in front of her
she was just got an off-the-shelf facial
detection library she wanted to use it
in a class project
and um it just wouldn't see her like it
wouldn't put that little box around her
head you know so she's like that's weird
she got her white friend that recognized
the white friend she got an asian friend
to recognize the asian friend
um and then she took a she had this like
white theater mask and she put on this
white theater mask and then it
recognized her face
right so we have to think about like
what's happening behind that system
is it that the um the engineers are
racist
no like the engineers were not like
sitting there being like yeah we're
definitely gonna discriminate against
uh black women but what happened is
um they had you know she she's a very
technical person so she
dug into the guts of the system and she
ended up writing a
really important paper called gender
shades uh with timnit gebru
where they audited the training data
libraries that are used to train these
kinds of systems
and in the resulting analysis that they
looked at it's sort of like
the problem of like what data are
available is often like the biggest
source of bias because in the case of
face data
these are celebrity and like political
people
profiles and so these are often the data
that are used to then
train the data sets um but then we can
think about well like
who's celebrity who's a political person
what kinds of racial
and gender biases are those it's going
to be like mostly white people mostly
men
um and in fact what they found is
something like and i'm creating the
exact figure but something around like
88
of the faces in this benchmarking
trading data set
um were what they called pale and male
so they were actually they didn't write
their race they were looking
just at the skin color um and so of
course
a system that's trained with that kind
of training data is going to fail really
badly like it works great for white men
because that's the kind of user group
that's really centered in that kind of
system
and then it works really terribly for
black women because there's so few
images of black women in that in the
training data
um and so it's sort of like thinking
about
it's not really that the algorithm is is
biased
it's that we are biased right and and
it's even also that even in building the
system so it's like the engineers
weren't sitting there being like hahaha
like let's be racist and sexist but also
they didn't have
mechanisms to seek out
the inherent racism and sexism that will
show up inevitably they didn't have the
tools to look for it
they didn't have the checks and balances
to be able to like
check for it uh before it ends up that
the the black woman discovers it on the
tail end of things and then
i mean um sort of it exposes it from
there
um and so that's it i mean sort of like
how we end up with these things is
because as we
build human systems we're pulling from
the human and social world
to train those systems and that world is
not a race
you know it's not a it's you know
hopefully one day we live in a world
where
like we are not you know racist and
sexist but right now the world is racist
and sexist
it's like that's you know garbage and
garbage out
exactly so we have to look for the
garbage basically
you can't travel faster than the speed
of light but what you might be able to
do is hire people
at nearly the speed of light with
indeed.com
indeed is the job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple
everything you need is in one place
including interviewing
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter
indeed instant match will provide you a
list of quality candidates whose resumes
are on indeed the moment you post a
sponsored job
and then you can invite them to apply
right away according to indeed data
candidates you invite are three times
more likely to apply for your job
than those who only see it on search
alone plus with indeed instant match
90 of employers get quality candidates
from indeed's resume database
as soon as they sponsor a job post
according to indeed data
so get started right now with a 75
sponsored job credit
at indeed.com mindscape
that will be an upgrade to your job post
at indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30th terms and conditions apply
that's indeed.com mindscape
well i mean this this really highlights
i think what to me is the
big looming philosophy question here
epistemology question or whatever you
want to call it about
objectivity i mean i can very crudely
distinguish between three attitudes
that we might have towards objectivity
one is objectivity is good
and we have it basically like the
science and computers and data are
pretty objective even if we humans are
flawed another attitude is you know
objectivity is something we should
aspire to but we don't have it we should
be extra careful in trying to get there
and a third attitude is
the the goal of being objective is just
misplaced in the first place we
shouldn't even try
we should recognize our you know uh
individual
non-objective goals so where do you sit
in that uh
classification scheme yeah
that's helpful the um so
i think what i would say you know and
this is where
i think some really interesting feminist
theory comes in too so folks like
donna haraway and sandra harding who
have thought through these questions
um really deliberately and specifically
we can draw a lot from them
so they have the ideas of something
called feminist objectivity
donna haraway specifically talks about
situated knowledge
and so you know i think where we
can't end up you know and and in fact
like i don't think any
well i shouldn't say that i don't think
any feminists would say but
i'm not i guess i won't speak for all
feminists but
because maybe some of them would say
this but like i think where we can't end
up i
i find it untenable a position of like
oh to everyone their own individualistic
truth and truth is super subjective and
everything is relative you know i think
that's untenable because
you know we have to be able to arrive at
some collective
uh shared understanding about the world
and um
you know i think it's very dangerous
when truth is just
fiction we've seen that happen recently
um and so like so i think that's that's
a very dangerous world to me
um and yet at the same time i think we
have to uh
recognize that the current conception
of objectivity as it exists has also
been
um exclusive like it hasn't been
including
um all people all genders all races
um all communities into this this sort
of uh
fold of objectivity and this is
something uh
feminists have critiqued for ages a more
recent critique
is ruja benjamin who calls this imagined
objectivity
and it's not to say that you know we've
done some just incredible
scientific achievements following these
kind of tenants of scientific method
and yet in particular when it comes to
how
sort of science and objectivity meet the
human and social world
our disciplinaryness is really
constraining for us
and you know it's like this is what's
sort of like leading to i think like the
some of the confusion on the part of the
technical community for like
how do we do this better and often when
you're trained in computer science
you're not given
like you haven't really been trained in
like gender studies
you know what i mean like you haven't
been trained in uh
history of race in the united states and
so like we're finding these places where
like
our knowledges haven't been able to um
like these these bodies of knowledge
need to meet each other and they they
haven't met each other and been
incorporated
um so i guess like in your scheme i
would be i think sort of
somewhere in the middle um you know i
think
one of the things that haraway would
tell us is that
all knowledge is situated so we're all
in a particular
kind of context you know we're in a
particular country
geography we have a particular value
system
and so um the strategy that feminists
would advocate for
what you would call strong objectivity
or feminist objectivity
which was something we pull in more
people
from more places and we try to recognize
more of our own blind spots more of the
ways in which
our kind of rigid conception of
objectivity may be
excluding people and so how do we bring
people to the table
um to understand the kind of cultural
and social boundaries of our knowledge
better
um so maybe that's a little bit
long-winded
[Laughter]
i think like that's it's like the
feminist or my feminist
uh kind of heritage would be like we
don't like throw objectivity out the
window
we definitely don't throw away like
collective knowledge making
but we do have to include more people
and we do have to um
break down some of the exclusionary
norms that end up pushing people out of
you know the quote-unquote
sort of objectivity i guess my
temptation upon hearing things like that
which
was actually very eloquently said and uh
and a lot of me wants to agree with
it but then there's part of me that
wants to say also make it even more
complicated
by saying you know look the charge of
the electron
is equal in magnitude and opposite in
sign to the charge of the proton and
that's not situated anywhere in
particular like that's everybody that's
absolutely universal so
i i guess i want to sort of imagine a
spectrum of situatedness of knowledge
where
there are some raw physical facts that
are pretty much universal
and some social statements we could make
that are pretty
obviously situated is that a fair way of
thinking
yeah i think so i mean i think like it's
sort of like the closer that we get
you know the closer we get to the human
and social world i think this is where
when we try to take sort of like
physical science sort of
laws for example and then apply those
to human circumstances i just feel like
it's a recipe for disaster
because like these kind of laws will not
and people try to do that like they try
to find well like like what's the
underlying grammar of a city
or what's the you know underlying law
that guides this particular kind of
human behavior
and the thing is that like humans are
just more complex than electrons i mean
maybe one day we could get there
you know what i mean in terms of like
having some laws that are going to be
like
oh catherine you know right after this
podcast is gonna go pat her cat
like we just know that about her right
so um
but but i think this is this is what
happens in the
the human world is that just things are
messy and there's so many variables that
the
the scientific method way of kind of
like well let's you know
take this one model and exclude all this
other stuff and just pursue this one
kind of model of reality down this
particular path like i think that can
work for certain kinds of things but
it really can't generalize and apply as
a method
to all these different human and social
circumstances so those are things that
we really need to
um understand as being contingent
and or like we may discover you know
some laws as it were facts that might
apply in
in more contingent circumstances so this
kind of applies
generally speaking in western cities
that have
uh this particular mode of
transportation you know what i mean and
that's still really useful knowledge
but it's also really useful to know that
it's only in this kind of city it's not
through all kinds of cities so i think
that's where um
the kind of proponents of unqualified
objectivity um can be irritating to
feminists
is is you know where you're trying to
make these um
somewhat absurd like universalist
statements or generalizations and
imagining that it's always about
generalizing and universalizing right
and so like
kind of understanding when when is
universalization and generalization
appropriate
and and when is it more appropriate to
just understand something that's deeply
situated and contingent in its own
circumstances and that's where a lot of
you know more qualitative
social science research comes in and
things like that i guess
what my response to that and i apologize
for talking
too much myself uh but but i'm working
through this in real time because it's
interesting um
it goes back to the shoes that we
started with right
and i guess one could say even with the
electron and the proton
you claim that's an objective fact about
the world but someone chose
to describe the electron as one particle
and the proton as one particle rather
than
you know different combinations or
different agglomerations you know there
was
some carving of nature uh that was human
that that we turned that we showed was
useful after the fact it's not
completely arbitrary there are good
reasons to do it
uh but it's still done by human beings
the difference being that when it comes
to fundamental physics
it's pretty easy to do that right it's
pretty straightforward to agree
on how to carve up nature that way and
when it comes to human beings or even
shoes
that's going to be much less easy much
more prone to
sneaking in our biases as some objective
measure of something
yeah yeah and i think variation you know
and and so like it's sort of like with
the proton and the electron it's like
it's gonna
um be able to behave in a particular way
and that's like super repeatable and
then you can kind of demonstrate just
even through repetition that this is
pretty much always how this particular
thing works whereas with shoes like if i
do the shoe experiment
in my neighborhood versus in a different
place versus with a different group of
students like it's going to be different
every single time
you know um and it's going to be
different actually in a similar way
i guess i should say because that's why
i use it as a learning exercise
um and so that but that's what gets
interesting to talk about is that
that sort of uh variation in that um but
it's not but it's not repeatable you
don't always come back with the same
result
and so like um and that's for me what
makes
a sort of data in the social and
political world the most interesting
thing because
they are contingent and yet they are
still useful
like we can still do meaningful things
with them like i said like their
reduction of the world
but hopefully they're a helpful
reduction that we can still use
in some meaningful way well thank you
for indulging my dissent into the
philosophical rabbit hole there but i do
want to come back to the data and the
feminism
um let's get some more examples on the
board because we talked about how
uh you make an algorithm you know for
facial recognition or for translation it
can be biased
uh you make the point in your book that
even the choice of which
data to collect uh smuggles in all sorts
of presuppositions right and there's a
whole bunch of data sets that
either should exist or should do exist
but don't include data
that they should exist i mean how should
people collecting the data
be thinking about these issues yeah
absolutely
um but you know and i think people
collecting data have a special
it's almost like a special kind of
responsibility right
um because you really do have to be
thinking about not only
sort of you know how are we going to
collect the data and store the data but
how are we going to steward the data
how are we going to provide information
like metadata about the data
in terms of who's going to come later
one of the
i think really complicated things
you know i find things like open data
really
interesting and useful and then also
complicated because it's sort of like
you have governments that are collecting
data and they're collecting it for like
a really specific
institutional purpose um and then
they're publishing it
often with really bad metadata like you
don't know like
where it's coming from or like what the
columns represent you have to do all
sorts of like legwork to figure that out
um and you know and but then imagine
that we can then use that to do
something else that the data were not
intended to do
so you know in fact like this is why i
have a lot of um
i think admiration i would say for
people in
sort of library sciences and in fields
that are about
stewarding information because it's
really about thing about like how do we
become
good caretakers of information and
not knowing when at the time of
collection
all of the possible ways that the data
might be used in the future
and so i think that's what that's that's
sort of what is complicated about it
because of course you can't anticipate
all those possible future uses and
you know other data sets that people
might want to combine it with to infer
something else or whatever
um so so yeah i mean i think um
but that's not to say like we shouldn't
do
we shouldn't collect data it's just to
say that we have to do it with
some of those caveats and and things in
mind
um and then i think you know in
particular for data feminism
we think in particular about ways that
structural forces of inequality like
sexism and racism
can enter that process so really um
tuning in to like what are those ways
that they enter
you know really obvious one is when you
collect gender data for example and so
like you know when we
are collecting gender data thinking
about you know first of all why are we
collecting gender data
um but then also thinking about how
you know it's you know 95
of the time when i'm filling out a forum
that is asking for my gender
there's only a binary choice but
they're far more than two genders um
and so kind of thinking very carefully
about how some of our categories that
we've sort of naturalized so like
this we inherit this like received
wisdom of like there's two genders one
fact there
aren't like empirically speaking there
are not two genders
um same with race sort of thinking about
like how do we
ask people to enter their race or how do
we racially identify people
all of these are i think really um
fraught but then even things that are
not overtly related to
say racism sexism gender race identity
categories
but then that can often be used to infer
those things so like
for example in the united states things
like
a zip code you can infer somebody's race
with something like 80
accuracy from their zip code because our
country is so segregated
um and so thinking about ways that even
collecting something like a zip code
can be racialized right like somebody
could use that or a system
even not even intentionally could end up
differentiating people and sorting
people
by proc sort of racially by proxy
through the zip code
um and so like these are the things to
think about as we're um
as we're collecting data is like what
what
data may reveal about us or about these
different group-based identity
categories that may
have implications downstream for
whatever system you're building
on the on the specific issue of the two
genders i just want to
for the audience's benefit say two
things number one uh
one of the very first podcasts i did was
with alex alice drager
and we talked about all the different
ways one can fail to fit into the
natural categories of the two genders
that we're most familiar with but then
also
in your book you have this lovely chart
that i had never seen before i don't
know if it was brand new with you if you
got it from somewhere
uh that traces all the different ways
you can end up in between
the traditional polls of uh biologically
male and female and this is not even
about
uh gender right this is about sex it's
just just biology
like you forget about psychology i love
yeah i love that piece uh it's a piece
from scientific american
and it's called like beyond xy and xx or
something like this
um and yeah it's a beautiful flow chart
and
the designers and the research team
looked across all the most recent
literature in sex differentiation um and
showed how
again like our received wisdom is that
like
there's like three maybe three sexes you
know male female and intersex
um and that it's like biologically
determined at birth
and then it's just set right and but
it's a beautiful flow chart
visualization
that shows how no in fact sex is
differentiated
and it unfolds it's dynamic and so it
kind of
over time yeah and it's it's uh i just
love the piece because it really
uh complexifies even in i would say um
gender studies
um because in gender studies there is
also received wisdom of like okay well
gender
is more of your identity and sex is
is a kind of biologic thing so even in
gender studies there's
that's the received wisdom there and so
i love that that piece is
uh kind of complexifying and challenging
that received with someone
well it's the word complexifying is
great here because that's a lot of the
work that you've set for yourself right
taking clear and easy distinctions and
sort of saying well it's not always
quite that simple
and the other thing i love about the
chart is there's nothing in there about
your feelings it's about
a mutation in this gene leads to a
decrement in this particular hormone
and yeah it's hard to look at the chart
and go oh you're denying the science
it's it's exactly the opposite of that
yeah no it's like showing the science
yeah it's just being honest it's
bringing us up to date about the science
actually that's right yeah
and uh the one other example i love
because it's just so direct and
relatable
is the crash test crash test dummies and
how uh
how they've affected ideas about safety
in cars
i'll let you tell that story if you want
to sure
yeah no so um for years and years um
we only used a male sized crash test on
these so these were based on you know
the statistical
average of the male body um
and in fact what this led to is that
uh pregnant people and women uh were
40 more likely to be injured or die in a
car crash
because we hadn't been basing it on
women's bodies
um so this is just such a such a
clear and also such a harmful
example of the ways in which um sort of
not just just a simple thing of like not
considering gender differences
in bodies right like just such a clear
example of that
um it's it's very similar too to like um
it was only fairly recently that the nih
mandated that
you have to have equal numbers of women
and men participants in
health research studies because for many
years women were
excluded from scientific research
due to evidently their menstrual cycles
um because like i i'm just imagining
like a bunch of men being like oh i
don't know
like they're weird like they have
menstrual cycles you know
like we definitely we can't include that
because that might mess everything up
you know um but but i just find that
like so interesting because
men have hormonal cycles too so it's
like their hormones will mess things up
with women's bill but anyway
um so yeah but i think that's like a
really clear example of this sort of
thing where
again it kind of goes back to this
objectivity question
of like you know true objectivity maybe
that
that would be great but we don't have it
yet
there's all these ways that we have
excluded and we are still pretty far
from
including um and so we have to work on
that well
the crash test dummy example um
is a good one because it seems like such
an obvious
mistake like if you're trying to be
objective and you know that different
people come with different size and
shaped bodies
isn't the most objective thing to do to
try to get the cross-section that is
fairest
as fair as possible of bodies but but
these human flaws and again sometimes
they might be pernicious but sometimes
they might just be
ah that's human beings we're finite
infallible you know they get in the way
i remember the story and i'm not gonna
get the numbers right
so i'm sure someone on the internet will
correct me but
sally ride when she was the first uh
female astronaut on the space shuttle
like they packed something like for a
week-long trip
thousands and thousands of tampons
because they're like well who knows
all you had to do was ask somebody right
like even if it was
all men doing the planning how hard
would it have been
to ask and that that got in the way
right i love this story yeah i know i
think this story is hilarious um
but it shows you how it's it's like
things like social stigma
how they shape our inability to even
have these conversations
right like the fact that they couldn't
ask her until she i don't know to open
up some cabinets or any other woman
yeah um so so yeah so i think i mean i
think that's the thing too is sort of
like
um if you just think about that as a
bias
but then like magnified up into like
what do we
like take on as a research subject in
terms of like you know
who's going to work on menstruation for
example like if
if the majority of scientists and health
let's say think that menstruation is
weird
like they're not going to work on it you
know or who's going to work on
um transgender health or who's going to
work on
uh segregation you know so it's sort of
thinking about like how these
taboos norms stigmas values
sort of human and social things they
creep in
and they they affect things and they are
pernicious
ways but they're not often um you know i
would say the majority of the time
they're not often from like some
one person's brain being like i'm gonna
do this
they're systemic they're part of this
sort of
you know again the systemic inequality
that we
swim in every day and so that's why it's
important to have a kind of
both a theoretical and kind of a
material understanding
of uh like what is what is this water
that we swim in
how do we look out for those things um
and how do we
ultimately create better work and better
science
by being able to to recognize those
things and
you know take steps to avoid them in our
own work well this is
i might be going i might be generalizing
too
glibly here but i think that this is one
of the reasons why
um the the tension about feminism
is particularly sharp in my own field of
you know physics and and
closely related fields of uh computer
science and philosophy and things like
that because
on the one hand there are fields that
valorize objectivity
and you know treating everyone equal
would be part of that goal
but on the other hand they make all
their money out of simplifying
things right and you know boiling things
down to the essence and treating things
like spherical cows
so this messiness of saying
well you know there's actually a lot of
heterogeneity in the in the sample and
things like that
is anathema a little bit to the method
that has been so empirically successful
in these
fields so there's there's a mismatch
there
which you know maybe shining some light
on it will make it a little bit better i
don't know
yeah no i think that's a really
important
observation and i and that and i still i
hold hope
for sort of like the
quantitative field i mean in a way what
i hold hope for is when i see
really excellent mixed methods research
you know
because i think we do get somewhere by
simplifying we just have to remember
that we simplified
you know what i mean you know it's like
we just again
we can't confuse the representation of
reality for the reality itself we can't
confuse the spreadsheet
for the the truth out there even though
they are interconnected they have a
relation there that's important
um and so i think for me
i get excited when i see sort of the
mixed methods and
one example like a concrete example i'll
give of this is um
mary gray has a book called ghost work
um
and that she wrote it collaboratively
and
her co-author is a computer scientist
she's an ethnographer and qualitative
researcher
and it's all about the sort of
behind-the-scenes
labor of the platform economy like so
uber
basically it's like all the people that
work behind the scenes
uh they showcase a lot of folks in india
for example that
they're kind of like helping the
algorithm along the way as it does
things they do human
in the loop sort of approvals of things
and checks on people's licenses
and stuff like that um and it's this
really lovely
study because you know mary will be
doing ethnography and interviewing
people like in their houses in india
and she'll surface an interesting
question and then her partner will go
test that
computationally and quantitatively
across a bunch of
network data and then he'll surface some
interesting questions and then she'll
kind of go try to validate those in the
interviews
and i get really excited by this kind of
work because i feel like it's building
on
sort of the strengths and the
limitations of both things because like
the qualitative work is like okay you
can interview like even if you interview
100 people in india it's not like you've
interviewed the population
you know um and then for the
quantitative work it's like okay you've
got all this really great
um coverage like in terms of scope and
scale
but then what explains the variation
right
and so i love how they can kind of go
back and forth and make it really sort
of
um multi-skiller and so that for me like
gets a little bit closer
at least when we're talking about the
things in the kind of human and social
and political realm
to being able to use these kind of
different fields methods to their best
advantage and in a complementary way
again to get further to like kind of
what is really explaining
some of this variation on the ground
yeah and
again if you put it that way who can
object to the idea that you know we
should have these richer methodologies
that we might find something out i don't
know but
uh people can be a little bit resistant
which i guess brings me to this question
i probably should have asked within the
first five minutes but
uh how do you define the word feminism
what does that what does that mean
to you that's one of the points of
contention which maybe it shouldn't be
right like
whether or not you think it has a
positive or negative connotation
sure yeah um so for us and there i
i should say there's there's many
feminisms um and
lauren and i in the book are
specifically pulling from intersectional
feminism
but at the very basic line
if you are a person who believes in
equality for all genders
you're a feminist like that and that's
that's kind of like the basic
definition um and that is feminism is it
a belief that all
genders are equal and there's a kind of
a
corollary to that because if you believe
that
all genders are equal and then you look
at the world around you
you can see that that equality has not
been realized in the world and so
feminism compels you to take action to
realize a world in which all genders are
equal
um and then and so i would say those are
those are two kind of like
indisputable things about feminism um
and then the sort of specific type of
feminism that we draw from
is uh called intersectional feminism
um and this is an idea out of black
feminism in the u.s
um where black feminists said you know
we cannot consider
um like gender inequality can't
explain our reality and it can't explain
social inequality because we can't we
have to take race into consideration
um and so that would be the basic idea
of
intersectionality um and so this idea
that we
include both sexism racism and then
since then you know other sort of forces
of oppression so think about like
classism or colonialism and so on so
that we can try to think
simultaneously and comprehensively about
how those forces intersect to produce
social inequality
um so that's that's the um
and i should say intersectionality is
pretty well established at this point so
that was around in the
late 80s early 90s and that is i would
say the dominant kind of uh
sort of feminist thought today i think
physicists would be a lot more
um in favor of the idea of intersection
sectionality if it were just labeled
non-linearity
i think that's what we would call it's
just great okay
maybe i'll i'm gonna say that next time
i speak to people because yeah i mean
if i understand it correctly it's just
the idea that whatever discrimination
you face
for being let's say uh a woman and black
is not just the discrimination you face
for being a woman plus
the discrimination you face for being
black they can interact non-linearly
yeah they can enhance exactly
yes that's exactly right yeah yeah yeah
okay i'm
to totally remember this i'm talking
like to to is this just in physics
uh any field that likes to have
equations non-linearity is
literally a feature of equations that
just says you can't add things
and get some the some of the effects is
not the sum of the causes
that's exactly kimberly crenshaw's
points it's like
it's like it's not reducible to these
like two separate things but they
combine
and interact the schrodinger equation is
linear but human beings are absolutely
not that's that's
pretty obvious but but the less obvious
thing i mean the thing that
you know your definitions of feminism
seem pretty transparent and
unassailable but the tricky part is that
you use the word equality
uh without quite digging into what that
means and if i pretend to be
uh you know hard-nosed about this i say
well what do you mean i mean the average
height of women throughout the world is
not equal to the average height of men
they're not equal in that sense so what
what do you mean
men and women all gender should be
treated equally
yeah i mean equality of
access to
services happiness
uh equality of opportunity uh
to promotions to etc um
an equality of power i mean i think like
this is when we'll know that we have
achieved feminist goals is
when we look at who's in power and it's
uh representative
of the population you know um
and you know it's just still we're so
far behind on so many things like in
terms of both
if you just look at like political
representation or if you look at like
the wage gap
um just all of these different markers
and measures
um and so i think that to me would be
like
this is this is when we'll have achieved
the world in which
we have equality of genders is when all
those measures of power have equal
representation
um yeah yeah i mean this is tough for me
um because well i had elizabeth anderson
on the podcast and you know equality is
her thing i'm not sure if you're
familiar with her work but
i don't know a leading theorist of
equality and uh
and people also you know the audience
members i can tell from youtube comments
etc
some of them get their hackles up
because they hear the word equality and
they instantly s
meet uh read that as a quality
of i don't know wealth right like
everyone has the same amount of wealth
or the same about of anything and
anderson's
point of view is much more nuanced and
it's more about you know the equality of
the ability to become who you want to be
or something like that right i can at
least
imagine a world where men and women have
exactly equal equality to become who
they want to be and a bunch of women
decide
that they don't want to be in positions
of power right i mean maybe that's not
the actual world because we're very far
from this
thought experiment of equal opportunity
but i i worry about
measuring it or judging it that way
because you know that's an outcome-based
measure and i want the uh it's like as a
poker player i know
that you can do the perfect strategy and
the outcome might not be what you want
or what what do you anticipate
right so um maybe we have to be a little
bit more
nuanced about the kind of equality that
we're shooting for here
yeah i mean i like anderson's definition
there sort of a quality it's an uh equal
opportunity to become who you want to be
or something like that i might have
mangled it so sorry elizabeth but yes
that's i think that's
the first of the idea um no and i
i like that and i do think like uh as
more women come into power we might have
uh
we might see a transformation of the
institutions themselves like yeah maybe
the institutions themselves will change
and look really different from what they
look like before
um because i do think there is a um
you know if you look at uh you know
other strains of feminism sort of that
are like kind of pushing women into the
corporate workforce they're like
being like hey be more like men you know
like uh you know wear your power suit
and yeah and whatnot
um and so i certainly don't think like
the
the goal is not just to like
fill the pipeline which is sometimes
where i get
um frustrated with that line of research
particularly in
stem which is not to say it shouldn't
exist like i'm glad people are thinking
about this
um but it's always framed as like where
are the women
uh not like why are the men taking up so
much space or something like that
like it's always like the women's
problem that they're missing
um and so um so yeah i mean i think like
institutions themselves will change
as different people both women and
people of color come into power
and that's possibly a really awesome
thing
so for example i'll say like for i i run
a research lab
um at mit um and i'm trying really
carefully to run it in a feminist way
in an inclusive way we have a kind of a
handbook we have a set of values and
norms
um we try to do our best within our
little scope and sphere of operation to
to push back against some of the sort of
toxic
academic culture that exists at um
at universities both for students and
faculty and staff
and so on um and so thinking about the
ways in which
and those are small interventions um but
i think they are potentially
transformative so i think it's right
that institutions themselves may
transform
in the process of realizing this this
sort of like equality of access
opportunity uh sort of freedom to be
come the person that you want to be and
so on well and this leads in
very well to sort of what i wanted uh to
ask for the last big
topic here which is uh we talked a lot
about how
not taking feminism seriously or not
taking uh
you know fairness uh in some broad sense
justice
seriously can lead to these uh
unintended
biases uh in data analysis and
processing and so forth so what about
the flip side i mean
can we use data or the analysis of data
or the collection of data
to bring about a better world can we you
know uh
be a proactive data feminist in that
sense
absolutely um so yeah and i'll give you
a really concrete example
uh which is my next project it's gonna
i'm working on it now and it's gonna be
my next book um
and in fact i sent the book proposal
today oh congratulations
um so one of the things i'm
looking at you may remember from the
book um
we talked about the case of maria
salguero who she
is collecting data about feminism in
mexico
so this is gender-based violence this is
when women are killed basically for
being women
and this could be what we call the
united states like intimate partner
violence
um but it's also happens in not only
with intimate partners but with other
family members it happens with sort of
drug trafficking
etc um and this is a big
topic in latin america governments are
passing laws about feminism
and yet they're not governments are not
systematically
tracking um feminicides themselves and
they're not kind of putting into place
the apparatus that would
enable them to like medical examiners to
label deaths as feminist sides and
things like that
and so maria salguero sort of steps into
this and for five years
she's been collecting data about
feminism from news reports
and she's ended up with the largest
public database of feminicide
in mexico and she's ended up sharing
data with journalists ngos
she's actually testified in front of
mexico's congress a couple times
um and you know we've talked about this
as this really interesting example of
sort of feminist counter data you know
so like kind of
collecting data in order to hold
institutions and societies accountable
for things that they are missing that
they are not doing
um and since then i ended up um
well i was living in uh argentina in
fact on sabbatical
and ended up i was really interested in
this and i started asking around
i started meeting other groups it turns
out she is not at
all the only one who's doing this
there's many groups across latin america
who are
doing this work you know they range in
size from people like maria who are
individuals to
large nonprofit organizations who are
mapping and monitoring
gender-based violence and so i've been
interviewing them and in fact my lab has
started building
uh technology to help them detect
feminist side better from news reports
because invariably they're using
news and social media to to tally
these uh killings um and so this is a
case
that is i think really interesting for
how we can
collect back or like monitor back or
really think about how do we use data
you know aggregate
these statistics as a way of holding
governments accountable
and building political will towards
social change to really like making a
case and building an evidence base for
changing policy um and so so yeah so i
think that's one example
i think there's many other examples out
there and um
in fact especially and that's one of the
reasons i'm also so committed to data
literacy is because i think
you know these are tools that can and
should be in the hands of
you know human rights groups uh
journalists who are doing some of the
most interesting sort of
accountability work with data right now
um
social movements community-based
organizations and
and so on so i think there's a lot of um
power and potential
of data science really for good like
that's what we're talking about here is
like data science for justice
so yeah and i think and along those
lines um
there was one of the points you made in
the book that you know
your sort of suggestions to do better
which really struck me was the blending
of reason with emotion or you're like
let emotion
exist don't be don't be afraid of it and
uh
and you can elaborate on why we should
do that and what it means but it's
it reminded me of a talk i heard
at mit by evelyn fox keller your mit
colleague about the dawn of the
scientific revolution and how
it wasn't completely organic
francis bacon and friends like would sit
down in the coffee shops and decide
what was science and how we do science
and how we go about it and
they made up a bunch of rules for
sounding more objective than we really
were right like
you know right in the second person uh
you know to explain that things couldn't
have been
any other way don't tell about all the
mistakes you made just tell the
successes and uh and it's not as
as necessary or inevitable it was a
choice
that was made along the way and so i
mean maybe give your point of view of
why
it's okay or even good to not always
try to sound as objective as we could
possibly be
totally yeah i know i'd love that um and
this goes back to the objectivity thing
in fact
right um because it's sort of like
when we have to put on that cloak of
objectivity
right we are um sort of trying to push
that other stuff under the rug like the
mistakes that we made the ways in which
our own
blind spots were maybe uncovered during
the process
and what uh the kind of feminist
approach would say is in fact
like we want to see that like that's
part of being transparent
in fact is not only telling this like
heroic
uh genius story of what some kind of
like discovery or new knowledge that we
made
but also showing those bumps in the road
showing the blind spots
showing how we got help and support like
that is in fact much more
um transparent along the way um
and then you know one of the things that
we say about
reason and emotion is that um
you know if what a kind of feminist
maxim is
whenever you encounter a binary you
should be deeply skeptical of it like
because usually it's hiding a hierarchy
um and usually it's empirically false
right so like
if like there's a gender binary men and
women like that's hiding uh
like it's just like false it's there's
more than two genders right
and we say this about the reason and
emotion as well like that's
often a binary that we encounter of like
reason
on the one hand emotion on the other
hand it's hiding a hierarchy reason is
usually seem to be on top and emotion is
this like
messy thing that's gendered that more
women are emotional or whatever
um and yet uh
there's this wonderful line from uh
patricia hill collins
um where she says like a kind of
feminist knowledge would be about
valuing
reason emotion and ethics um sort of
equally
on an equal playing field um
and the reason to do that is like again
sort of acknowledging
the situatedness of our own knowledge
and our own selves like it's about being
transparent about our own limitations
and the fact that
we have emotional motivations for
studying things
for doing things and then when we
communicate our knowledge
communicating with emotion is a way to
make it
accessible to other people as well so
using emotion and communication is a way
of being
inclusive and this i think comes in
particular with data visualization which
can be seen as a very
um you know it can be seen as a very
scientific technical specialized way of
communicating which is
fine if what you're doing is it's in a
scientific journal or something
um but when you're doing it more for a
general public
it can be sort of it's like a gated
community it's like letting certain
people in
and it's prohibiting access by other
people so thinking through about like
what are ways that we engage
emotion that we engage like multimodal
sensibilities for people to access um
whatever
sort of messages with the data so like
it
emotion brings all these things into our
toolkit of communication that are lost
if you're like no
it must be neutral objective
and appear scientific or whatever so
well you know david hume one of my
favorites uh said that reason
isn't should be the slave of the
passions right i mean reason
gets us what our passions uh tell us
is what we want in in some sense so they
need to go uh
hand in hand it reminds me a little bit
what you just said of um
controversies in news reporting from
wars
and things like that where you're
allowed to say how many people died but
the government will try to prevent you
from showing pictures of those dead
people i mean in principle no extra
information is conveyed
but the emotional resonance is a very
different thing and that that matters
right
yes absolutely yeah there's a really
interesting piece
now i'm forgetting the author but it's
something like
numbing with numbers or something it's
this really interesting piece about
um how often we are moved by the story
of one
sort of unjustified death but not by
numbers describing
kind of mass death and sort of it's it's
a really interesting philosophical
reflection on that and then like sort of
also how do you
how do we communicate the scale of
things like a genocide or
this kind of mass extermination events
at a scale that is
meaningful to us as human beings and
doesn't just numb us into
feeling disempowered by the
the scale of it or something like that
but i always like to end the podcast
on a more or less optimistic note if
possible so i mean maybe say one more
thing about how great it is that we can
use data
and analysis and all these things to
make the world a better place
yeah not end on death
uh yeah so you know i think
lauren and i talk a lot about um you
know in data feminism we try to describe
some of the ways that uh our data are
infected and polluted by the
inequalities that we
encounter in the world but at the same
time
we do pause it and advance the idea that
data are also part of the solution
and so really thinking about ways in
which we put
that power of data into the hands of the
people who come really make
social change and use data to challenge
those same structural inequalities that
keep showing up over and over again in
our data sets and in our
systems and did i hear correctly there
uh
this is the most important controversy
of all that we haven't even mentioned
you treat data as plural not singular
oh well we flip back and forth when we
talk about
big data we tend to use singular
because it's like big data is blah blah
but if i'm talking about a
data set like a collection of things
then i tend to use plural but i probably
slip and go back and forth you know look
there there you go complexifying the
world for us
once again i feel like physicists should
like complexity right aren't you
about no no kicking and screaming they
would like everything to be a perfect
sphere as far as
concerned honestly but complexifying is
a good thing for human beings when when
they're not doing physics
and with that in mind catherine dignazio
thanks very much for complexifying our
worldview here on the mindscape podcast
lovely thank you it was a pleasure
[Music]
you